today I want to talk to you about which
blockchain is the best blockchain yeah
are you ready so first of all let's
let's ask the audience so all together
you shout out which you think is the
best blockchain on three one two three
fantastic and that's what subjective
experience is all about because we all
have opinions right and opinions really
don't matter they don't because it
doesn't matter if in your opinion it's
the best blockchain or not well maybe it
does matter if you're a trader and
you're trying to guess what everybody
else thinks is the best blockchain and
really it's all about perception I'm not
going to tell you which is the best
blockchain because I think that's a
ridiculous question to even ask it's
it's a bit like asking what is the best
car or what is the best pair of shoes
you could get well it depends right it
depends on what you want to achieve it
depends on what you want to do with the
car or the pair of shoes you ask one
person what the best pair of shoes is
and they'll tell you strong hiking boots
great you ask someone else what the best
pair of shoes are they're gonna say
Manolo Blahniks now have you ever tried
to go hiking in Manolo Blahniks have you
ever tried to do a fashion show in
hiking boots yeah what would work so
well right so purpose matters the
purpose you're going to use the tool for
matters and the purpose determines what
is the best blockchain for your purpose
the general question what is the best
blockchain makes no sense because you
have to
add the purpose you can ask the question
what is the best blockchain for my
purpose what is the best cryptocurrency
for my purpose but you can't ask what is
the best period that makes no sense now
if you start reading the marketing
brochures I'm sure they will contradict
what I just said because a lot of them
will tell you this blockchain does
everything it's scalable it's secure
it's fast it does smart contracts and
sounds money and it's quantum resistance
and super private and it uses
military-grade encryption which just
means 128 bit encryption it's [ __ ]
right which is the purpose of a
marketing brochure of course and a lot
of people will tell you a lot of things
about their favorite project but you
should really ask what is the purpose
what are you trying to achieve in
architecture there's a great term in the
80s which is form follows function and
the idea is if you have a building the
way it looks should tell you about what
it's used for the form should follow the
function the architecture of the
building should reflect what it's going
to be used for and the same thing
applies with block chains the
architecture of the system should
reflect what it's going to be used for
but that's a very very difficult thing
to do it's a difficult thing to do for
architects it's a difficult thing to do
for software engineers it's a difficult
thing to do for product managers if it's
a commercial system it's even more
difficult in open-source public open
block chains which quite honestly are
the only ones I care about and think are
interesting
it's difficult because there are many
opinions about what a blockchain mites
do or should do or what its primary
purpose is pick any one of the open
public projects that exist today ask 20
developers who are working on the
project what is this thing supposed to
do and they'll give you 20 different
answers it sounds money it's digital
cash it means big blocks it needs small
blocks it's for smart contracts it can
do everything what does it do for you
that's a more interesting question you
have to decide what fits the application
you're trying to build and that's the
question that doesn't get asked a lot
and you can tell it doesn't get asked a
lot because people try to apply
blockchain technology to a whole bunch
of things that don't need a blockchain
I've considered wearing a t-shirt at all
the conference's I go to that say you
don't need a blockchain for that
whenever I do a hackathon and they
present applications they're like we
have put digital music on the blockchain
you don't need a blockchain for that you
don't need a blockchain for that why do
you need a blockchain for that just have
it on a sign and I'll just pick it up
every time you don't need a blockchain
for that why what does blockchain do
it's not a database it's not somewhere
where you work or digital signatures you
don't need a blockchain for that it's
not a content database you certainly
don't need a blockchain for that it's
not scalable or efficient it is
decentralized and very very secure and
for the ones I care about very robust
against censorship and interference
meaning that it keeps running even when
very powerful people or organizations
want to stop it
from running for that you need a
blockchain but what kind and how would
you design that and now let's talk about
the engineering challenge as an
architect when you're building these
systems you have to make choices some of
these choices start at the very early
stage like for example do I want to
build something that is very specific or
do I want to build some things that has
a broad generic purpose why don't we
just do both
you can't do both the things that are
need to be very specific have to be
optimized for that one purpose and in
doing so they're no longer flexible
enough to do the general purpose and the
things that are general-purpose don't
have the unique characteristics you need
for very specific applications that
should be a very conscious decision at
the beginning some block chains are
designed for rather specific
applications and some lock chains are
designed to do rather generic
applications and both claim they can do
both once you've decided on that first
question you then have to make further
decisions all of which involve
intractable trade-offs intractable
trade-offs means trade-offs that I can't
get both sides I have to choose and that
choice then determines the path that
that block chain will take as a designer
as a developer as an architect you don't
get to tell the market how they will use
your product if you try to get too
specific the market may decide that it's
not suitable for what they need and if
you make it generic enough and you have
one type of application in mind the
market may decide to use it for a
completely different type of application
hopefully they will because as an
engineer as a designers you don't have
the exclusive knowledge of what other
people needs because there's too much
variety you can't imagine what kind of
things people might need in other places
in the world that you don't understand
under different circumstances than your
own and you certainly can do that across
a broad timeframe we're building systems
here that might last should last will
last decades what do people need today
what do people need in 30 years very
different so the designer the software
developers who are making these very
careful trade-off decisions have to
consider that they're making those
decisions with incomplete information
and that even if they try to design
something with very specific
applications in mind the market may
decide to do something completely
different
back to architecture in the 1960's and
1970's in California they made swimming
pools in organic shapes no longer square
they made them with curves right have
you seen those types of swimming pools
and then there was a big drought so for
a couple of years it was forbidden to
fill your swimming pool because it was
not enough water and guess what happened
next
skateboarding exploded across California
because skateboarders saw those curves
and thought if I stand on the edge and I
kick down oh we could have some fun with
this and all of the swimming pools in
California that had been designed in the
60s with curves became the first skate
parks
skateboarding wasn't a big thing before
then and it mostly involved going in
straight lines and that sport was
transformed do you think the swimming
pool designers could imagine that ten
years after they made a swimming pool
some snotty kid would stick a board with
wheels and start whizzing around because
it was empty no form follows function
sometimes sometimes it doesn't sometimes
the form follows the function the
designer thought it would have and then
the market says I have another function
that fits perfectly for this type of
curve you can never know how that's
gonna play out and the same thing is
going to happen with block chains
ultimately the users decide the markets
decide you can have all of the design
ideas and here we are arguing maybe
we'll have a panel here there will be
six very serious experts and they'll say
it's really a store value and somebody
else will say it's a medium of exchange
and somebody else will say but it can't
be a unit of account because it's not
scalable enough or it's too volatile or
whatever and someone will say maybe you
should do more with smart contracts and
they don't know what they're talking
about because they don't get to decide
these are opinions but they're not users
users get to decide you can make
something that kind of fits better into
a store value model or kind of works
best for smart contracts the designers
of Bitcoin and the developers of Bitcoin
had some ideas about it being digital
cash and for some period of time it
plays digital cash for some period of
time it plays speculative gambling
casino money and for some period of time
it plays store value is
especially in countries where their
currency is distressed which of those
will it be we don't know it depends it
depends on a lot of factors we don't
know yet about it depends on what
happens to national currencies it
depends on what happens to inflation in
Europe it and the u.s. and Japan it
depends on how the world transforms it
depends on whether cash as it exists
today will still exist in 15 years all
of these factors that have nothing to do
with Bitcoin the designers of aetherium
had certain applications in minds with
their smart contracts mostly engineering
applications did they think it would
become a platform for launching a 10,000
scams and pump-and-dump
no it was very good at that because a
generic platform that allows flexibility
to build whatever smart contract you can
imagine will attract the kind of person
also who is going to build their
beautifully engineered pump and dump
scheme with a smart contract does that
change what etherium does no it just
means that that was a niche that the
market decided was really hot why
because a whole bunch of naive investors
and even more naive venture capitalists
were throwing as much money as possible
into this new space two years ago you
could attach blockchain to any other
word and make some things that a VC
would throw a couple million dollars at
you
music blockchain movies blockchain Real
Estate's blockchain blockchain real
estate asparagus blockchain blockchain
asparagus 2 million dollars for you sir
that sounds fascinating or you could
even combine it with the other cool
words you could say we will cultivate
asparagus with blockchain based
artificial intelligence otoño
flying drones that way you could check
all of the boxes and then they throw
tens of millions of dollars at you none
of it made sense the market not only
decides but sometimes the market is
stupid it's crazy it's irrational it's
driven by sentiments and emotion and
over the next decade things will calm
down people will figure out you don't
need a blockchain for that
how will they figure that out they'll
invest their money they'll lose their
money they'll invest their money they'll
lose their money by the third time most
smart investors start picking up on that
pattern some less smart investors it
might take them 10 or 15 rounds the
bottom line is there is no best for
every purpose and the people who are
involved every day in making difficult
trade-offs cannot design for a purpose
that's too specific because that's
limiting and may miss what the market
wants to do or miss the timing and they
can't design for something that's too
generic because it won't have enough
powerful capabilities to solve real
problems that we have and they have to
make difficult trade-offs you can't
simply be scalable and decentralized and
secure and fast you can't in engineering
terms there are some fundamental
trade-offs we call these dilemmas or try
Alma's sometimes a classic trilemma is
you can't design for security
decentralization and scalability pick
two right so in a trial MA you can only
do two of the three things
at the same time if you make something
that is scalable and secure it's not
decentralized or it will be less
decentralized if you make something
that's scalable and decentralized it
won't be as secure if you make something
that's decentralized and secure it won't
be as scalable and then of course
there's the blockchain that will tell
you we do all three in the trilemma and
what that means is they don't understand
the trade-off which is even more
dangerous there's two possibilities ally
or ignorant and ignorance is far worse
if you don't actually understand that
trilemma it's a bit like how I used to
tell my consulting clients I can deliver
the solution it will be fast it will be
cheap or it will be great pick two I can
do fast and cheap it won't be great I
can do cheap and great it won't be fast
and I can do fast and great and trust me
it won't be cheap that's the essence of
a trial Emma we face these things every
day in life and we understand
intuitively that life involves choices
think of it as a journey when you open
the left door and go one way you have
chosen not to take the right Road you
can never go back and take that road all
the roads that come off that are gone
you've made your choice when dealing
with trying to build the best blockchain
for a specific purpose every choice you
make whether you know it or not
closes many possibilities so next time
someone asks you what is the best
blockchain instead of shouting out your
for it favorite product or project ask
for what thank you very much
yes hello hello address so my question
is today you were specifically talking
about blockchain yes I want to know what
is your opinion about different kinds of
disability the major technologies for
example like directed acyclic graphs
there was some presence I think
yesterday from hadera for example how
probable you think it is that a newer
kind of distributed ledger technology
solves the Box chain trilemma
and it's used and it's widely adopted in
the future so most distributed ledger
technologies that I've seen our
permission systems or they involved
Federation's of permissioned consensus
players from that perspective they do
not address the primary aspect of open
public blockchains which is censorship
resistance if you have known identifying
participants in the consensus
environment those participants can be
coerced they can collude and they can
attack the system itself so I'm highly
skeptical of distributed ledger
technologies for serving the open
cryptocurrency problem for serving other
problems like if you currently have one
company clearing all of the equities in
a stock exchange would it better would
it be better if instead of one you had
five yes that's an improvement
but that's not an improvement compared
to an open public blockchain that has
tens of thousands of participants in
consensus that's a massive degradation
so if you go from the 1970s banking
system that is centralized down to a
point of one right and you have the
massive amount of corruption and
front-running and all of the other
transparency problems you have in these
markets going from one to five or from
one to a hundred
that's an improvement but those don't
solve censorship issues
no one's censoring the rich right that's
not really a problem they can work
around censorship
there's no censorship problem in those
markets and it can solve problems in
those markets primarily around
corruption and transparency but I'm not
interested in that that's not the area
I'm interested in
[Music]